yeah welcome to this video playing fight
to the end from Sweden and we got Slav
gap what can i play let's play this one
had a quite similar on line before
alright so we got the chiba nenko and i
really have forgotten most of my theory
here what's this one i sent this one
with a phone
yeah I have played this line with black
quite often but I must admit I'm it
seems that I have forgotten most of it
the idea of this setup is this a form
advanced trying to get to the somewhat
weak pawns queen a three years the idea
threatening to take the main drawback of
all this is of course the Dwight loses
quite substantial on the amount of time
but Kim that some that's interesting why
does try to hope and what is trying to
hope this is great English white is
trying to point out that c4 is a week
sd-6 is a week pawn and in the some mg6
yeah okay I thought Bishop f4 would be
good maybe can he can operate also with
them with the exchange sex as possible
night h5 for example go ahead go here
hmm yeah first impression now I think
what what should be in really good shape
here maybe I'm always the meeting things
it looks it looks nice yeah the question
is what about the bishop
yeah just back probably hmm yeah i
thought maybe i have some some more
forceful this is a 5 is really ambitious
not saying that it's necessarily bad
it's just very ambitious okay how to
continue
this intense Queenie to at some point
and taking on d5 like to sacrifice them
it really would open up various
attacking possibilities okay I need to
look on the phone
yeah you must be cautious it can easily
turn out that the bishops are not so
great
but their weaknesses on e6 for example
that complicated stuff
check
yeah maybe night takes is good with
Queen edge for coming okay I need to
time to the to the rookie oh all that
hurts I didn't I didn't look at this at
all Wow
ah just blundered this pawn what deck
hmm
okay I just hope that Queen edge for us
not working that probably it isn't
working at least not immediately
yeah well
we can still still fight
still have some activity it's not really
enough objectively but that's it's
something wait I can take it take care
and through yet he will look that one
trick 9006 wow this was very very lucky
just the rook right the average a stroke
yeah fully bad play with me it was
probably a very good position at the
beginning but then I really screwed this
up badly okay now fortunately like has
nothing to attack him so he can really
move quickly okay
I know no stay mad please that's
actually an immediate made yeah very
lucky that he fell for this trick I
don't know at the beginning I thought
this should be it should be quite good
for white I mean here this this kind of
this kind of a position ah what deck so
they can just take b5 here what did that
do that it's very typical at this movie
and this is very typical for this line
and I just didn't play it it wins
instantly something like this is it's
over it's plus 2 just plus 2ei cannot is
completely tied down wow really a bad
game I mean it is this really just just
normal the sacrifice why didn't I
consider that I mean okay this this
looks nice but it's probably not doing
much this Bishop move 95 again wins wow
this is this idea okay okay but this is
far from being being trivial that this
wins this is a computer stuff the
computer kind of move the ideas here and
here well now okay this like this I
cannot see nor did a blitz gay Middle
East and yeah here the black is fine
okay the dumb was fairly normal up to
the point where I just blended the porn
then yeah this this just blunders it
back yeah okay yeah I need to be lucky
once in a while but really the the big
point was here with 95 in this position
alright thanks for watching